J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE:
Since it's going to take a
minute for this to start up,
I'll show you a
demonstration here.
It's a way to make tea.
It's a really clever device
called a Soxhlet extractor.
And it was invented in order to
extract stuff from like bark or
leaves or something like that.
Something that's very insoluble.
So you could imagine to do it
like tea.
You put it in a filter paper,
pour solvent through it, some
of it dissolves, it goes on
through, and then you have to
concentrate the solution.
But there's another way to do
it, which is to
use this thing here-
How are we doing?
Let's see if I can get the
show up here.
So the idea is that the problem
with that is that the
stuff isn't very soluble.
It takes an enormous amount of
solvent to get it out.
So what was invented by this man
Soxhlet-
and I'm having trouble here.
It says audience.
Why is this not on?
Oh.
Somebody's unplugged it.
Sorry for the confusion here.
We're technically challenged
today.
There we go.
OK.
So what we have here is a flask
down below that's going
to have the solvent, and not
very much solvent.
Let me get it like that.
And so we're going to boil the
solvent.
It's going to come up through
this arm here, up to a
condenser, and then drip into
the tea leaves, or whatever it
is we want to extract, held in a
little cup inside here.
And it's solid down here, so
this is just a cup.
But there's this funny snakelike
tube that comes from
the bottom of this, up, around,
down, and back inside,
toward the flask.
So watch what happens when I
pour some liquid in here.
So if you just pour water
through a filter, the water
runs through very rapidly.
It doesn't have time to become
saturated.
So it's inefficient in two ways.
You've got to pour lots of water
through, and it doesn't
get saturated on the way
through.
This way, the liquid you
distilled up drips down in
there, sits with the stuff,
which is held, remember, in
like a filter paper inside here.
And you can see that the
liquid--
see if I can get it so you can
see.
Did you see that the liquid went
not only of course in
here, where it's with the tea
leaves, but also through tube
and up that far?
So it's there.
You can see the meniscus in the
side arm.
Now, what's going to happen when
I pour a little more in?
Drip, drip, drip, actually, of
course, from a condenser.
It's getting right up to the top
of that side arm.
What's going to happen?
So it's sitting there and
becoming saturated.
Then we go a little bit more.
What's it doing?
It siphons, right?
But it sits there with the hot
liquid until
it gets to the top.
Then it draws all that off.
And then what happens?
More liquid boils up and comes
in and dissolves.
It's the same liquid, of course.
It's been distilled now.
So it comes on up, and pretty
soon--
it'll go a little quicker this
time, because there's are drops
in the side arm.
And it drains again.
So you use just a small amount
of liquid over and over again.
And there are no moving parts,
right, except the boiling and
the liquid.
So it's really beautiful design
of a clever apparatus,
if you want to make tea
efficiently.
Now this is starting up.
And if I'm lucky, it will have
backed up my most recent work.
It's got almost all of it.
That's good.
See if it will come
on here.
Yeah.
OK.
Thanks for bearing with me.
So a little more about the
reactivity of acid
derivatives, and then on to the
sugar glucose proof, one
of the finest logical creations
of
the 19th century--
or ever.
First, alkylation.
We started talking about this
last time, about the fact that
an enolate has partial charge,
both on the
carbon and the oxygen.
So if you want to put an alkyl
group on
by an SN2 type reaction--
what's the problem?
STUDENT: Are you rehearsing
timings?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: Are you rehearsing
timings?
PROFESSOR: Oh, thank you.
One more time into the breach
here.
John is on the button about
whether I'm
rehearsing the timings.
OK.
So the question is whether you
react with the carbon or the
oxygen when you do SN2, when you
react with methyl iodide.
Now, you could do a calculation
and see where the
HOMO is, right?
The HOMO looks like that.
It's a pi orbital, obviously,
with one node, in addition to
the p orbitals that
it's made of.
And that's big on the carbon.
So that would favor reaction on
the carbon.
And the attack would be from the
top, because it would come
in on top of the p-orbital of
the carbon.
On the other hand, if you look
at the electrostatic
potential, the energy a proton
would have on the surface of
this molecule when it's in
contact with it, it's not the
most favorable at the position
of the HOMO.
It's minus 143 kcal/mole for a
proton that
would be there.
But a proton here is minus 170
kilocalories per mole.
And notice that it not only
favors the oxygen, but it's a
sigma attack, rather than a pi
attack.
So you could imagine either of
these positions attacking the
methyl iodide.
Now, in fact it turns out-so
that if it attacked the
carbon, it would attack from the
top, as shown up here on
the right, out of the plane.
If it attacked the oxygen, it
would attack in the plane.
And in fact, the major product
is attack on carbon with
methyl iodide.
And it's a negligible amount of
O methylation.
But it's not always that way.
If you have a different reagent,
a different
electrophile to be attacked by
the nucleophile--
for example, silicon--
displace chloride--
then it turns out to be just the
other way.
It goes on oxygen, 85% yield,
and a negligible
amount on the carbon.
So this is obviously a finely
balanced thing, and it's not
something that you're going to
be able to predict.
This is a part of lore,
which things go where.
Now, if you use a strong anion
base to extract a
hydrogen adjacent to the
carbonyl to make the enolate,
its pKa is 12 units
higher, so that the equilibrium
lies completely to form the
enolate anion.
But one could imagine two
different enolate anions, where
a proton's been taken from the
right or from the left.
So there's another question
about possible reaction
mixtures, when you react this
with methyl iodide.
And if it's done with two
equivalents of methyl iodide--
this was done by Professor House
at MIT--
he found that 41% of the product
alkylated on the CH2
group, and 9% alkylated on the
group that had a methyl group
attached to it already.
But these aren't very good
yields.
There was also 22% of recovered
starting material.
So the question is, where did
the proton come from that went
on to the recovered starting
material?
Now, this was done by adding
methyl iodide
to the enolate solution.
So there's just a little bit of
methyl iodide there that
reacts and makes the ketone, one
of these two
ketones down here.
But then, additional enolate
could abstract a proton from
one of these, and that could
become the new enolate.
That could be where the proton
came from to make
the starting material.
And in fact, 21% of the product
has a second methyl
added, and 6% of the product has
three new methyls added to
the compound.
So it's a real dog's breakfast.
It's not the way
you want to do this kind of
thing.
It's a very inefficient
reaction.
There are other ways to do it,
like for example, use lithium
diisopropylamide, another really
strong base.
This is done at very low
temperature.
And then the people who did this
put in manganese
dichloride in a complex with
lithium chloride, again at
-78 degrees, and they made a
different enolate anion, the
one with manganese as the
counterion.
And then they added to this 1.3
equivalence of benzyl
bromide and a different solvent,
the
n-methylpyrrolidone.
And did that at room
temperature.
Notice this is lore.
This is a lot of fine
description of exactly what
solvents, what temperatures, and
so on--
how you do it.
And under those conditions, they
were able to get 88% of
this single product after
distillation.
Right?
So it's the pure stuff.
It's possible to do these
alkylations as a very high
yield reaction.
Now, this is what's called
an "Org. Syn. Prep."
When there's a very valuable
technique that people would
like to be able to repeat, it's
submitted by the people
who created it and checked by
people at this at this Organic
Syntheses operation, and then
they publish it.
And then you can believe that if
you try it, you'll be able
to do it here, because it's been
checked.
So things that are an "Org. Syn.
Prep." have been very carefully
done, and all these conditions
are there.
But it would be very difficult
ahead of time to figure out
exactly all the tricks you need
to do it.
But you can look it up in
Organic Syntheses.
OK.
LDA can also be used with
carboxylic acids.
So we want to make the enolate.
We want to extract that red
proton.
Can you see any problem involved
when you treat this
with a strong base?
Megan?
What's the name of this starting
material?
What kind of compound?
STUDENT: Carboxylic acid.
PROFESSOR: Why do they call it
a carboxylic acid?
STUDENT: It gives up protons.
PROFESSOR: Because it gives up
protons.
Is that the proton it gives up?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
It gives that one up.
So you don't get the enolate.
However, this is a strong enough
base that it's possible
to pull off a second proton and
in fact get the enolate,
which lacks the [correction:
insert second] negative charge
that's supposed to be there.
And then that can react with an
alkyl bromide at the more
nucleophilic, less stable anion
center, and give a good
yield of the alkylated acid.
It's also even better, of
course, to do dicarbonyls,
which are more strongly acidic,
so you don't need
these really strong acids
[correction: bases].
So you use ethoxide to do this.
It's acidic enough that you
could imagine using hydroxide.
But you don't use hydroxide to
do this.
You use ethoxide.
Can you guess why you use
ethoxide rather than hydroxide?
As always when you begin to get
complicated reactions, and
this is not a very complicated
one, there are several ways
things can react.
And this is not...as in the last
case, where you could pull off
the wrong proton.
In this case, the base can not
only pull off the proton, it
can also act as a nucleophile.
And what would it do as a
nucleophile? Jack?
STUDENT: Attack the ester.
PROFESSOR: Hydroxide would
attack the ester, right?
OH minus would come on, -OEt
would come off, and
you would convert the ester to
an acid, which would react
with the strong base, hydroxide,
and that would be
the end of the line.
Because you don't have this
really super strong base that
could pull off two protons.
But if you use ethoxide and it
attacks here, who cares?
One or the other the other
ethoxides is going to come off,
and you're back where you
started again.
Right?
So then it's possible to wait
until you
pull that proton off.
OK.
So that compound is a
beta-ketoester.
It's got a ketone in the second
carbon
from the ester group.
OK.
So you make the anion and react
it with an R with a leaving
group, and now you treat it with
hydroxide.
Right?
Because what you were really
after was getting this acid
with an R group on it.
But you don't use OH minus for
that.
Or you could use two esters to
make the thing acidic.
Do exactly the same stuff and
get the R on, now with two
acid groups.
And of course, it would be
possible to do it a second
time, and put a second R group
on while it's still an ester,
before you add the hydroxide.
OK.
So you can put alkyl groups on
these beta-ketoesters or
malonic ester.
The CH2 with two carboxylate
groups on it is malonic acid.
OK.
Now, you might want those
compounds.
Or we already, in fact, saw
using cyanoacetic ester.
You remember when we saw that?
We used it where R was this, R
with the leaving group.
It was the Mitsunobu procedure
that we went through and
showed that that also can
hydrolize the CN group, the
nitrile as well, to give a
second carboxylate groups.
But mostly, people aren't after
this.
What they're after is
protonating those to give the
beta-keto acid or the malonic
acid.
Why did I draw it that way?
Do you remember?
STUDENT: Because in that
structure the H is shared.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
I can't hear well.
STUDENT: The H is somewhat
shared between the two Os.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The H, of course, would be
hydrogen bonded to this
oxygen, but it can do more than
that.
Remember from when we were
talking about
the Mitsunobu reaction?
We can do this, which results in
decarboxylation
when we heat it.
And those are enols, which of
course can isomerize to the
related ketone, or on the second
case, into an acid.
So the real purpose of using
this beta-ketoester or the
malonic ester is to put the R
group on, and
then get these compounds.
So it's another way of getting
to what was effectively that
enolate, except having the
second carbonyl on made it
easier to get.
You didn't need to use those
really strong basis.
So you can you can synthesize an
alkylated acid or an
alkylated ketone, alkylated in
the alpha position, by using
these dicarbonyl compounds.
The one on the top is called
acetoacetic ester synthesis.
Because when this was still an
ester here, this was CH3
acetoacetic acid.
So it goes by way of that to get
the ketone.
Or this one, as we said, was
malonic ester that we started
with to get the acid.
Notice that these are ways of
adding to
the R group two carbons.
Either with a ketone--
I mean, it would be another
carbon, of course, if it were
a ketone-- or two carbons here
to make an acid.
And so when one's thinking about
synthesis, you try to
think about how to put more
carbons on.
Remember the Arndt-Eistert
procedure, we talked about
with diazomethane, or cyanide,
displacing chlorine from an R
group, or making a Grignard out
of the alkyl halide, and
then adding CO2?
Those all add one carbon to the
chain.
But this thing adds two carbons,
at least, or more, in
the case of this, when you have
an R group there.
And remember adding a
nucleophile to open an epoxide
also adds two carbon.
So if you're in the business of
organic synthesis, these
things become second nature.
I need to add this, aha, I would
use that reagent or that
reagent or that reagent.
OK.
Then one of the most important
reactions is the aldol
condensation.
It was discovered first with
acetaldehyde, which, treated
with base, makes the enolate.
But it can react with itself.
And then when you protonate the
O minus, you get this
compound, which, in the case of
acetaldehyde, this
particular one with a methyl
group here and a CH2 group
here, has the name aldol.
So this is called the aldol
reaction.
It makes aldol.
But you can make it with other
groups here as well, not just
with the methyl group.
And so generically they're
called aldols.
Obviously the name is aldehyde
and alcohol, aldol.
But it can be dehydrated.
Lose the OH and an H down here
to give
the unsaturated aldehyde.
Now an aldol is a
beta-hydroxyaldehyde.
And this is an alpha,
beta-unsaturated aldehyde.
So these are things that when
you're looking at something
you want to make, and you see,
aha, it's a beta-hydroxycarbonyl
compound, or it's an alpha,
beta-unsaturated
carbonyl compound, you think,
the aldol reaction.
If I assigned you a zillion
problems to do that, that
would become second nature to
you.
If it turns out that that's
important to you, you will do
a lot of problems with it, and
it will become
second nature to you.
Now, I've shown it here
base-catalyzed, but it can be
acid-catalyzed as well, and I
would expect you to be able to
figure out how the mechanism
would
work with acid catalysis.
Now, the equilibrium for this is
favorable, because this
isn't very crowded with H and H
here, and Hs is
down here, and H here.
But if you start with a ketone
instead of an aldehyde, then
the product is more crowded and
less stable.
So if you start with acetone
instead, and make the anion,
and try to do this reaction, and
make the beta-hydroxyketone
now, you find that the
equilibrium is unfavorable.
So you'd like to figure some
trick, if that's the compound
you want, that would allow you
to get over there.
One way is not to start with the
ketone, but to start with
the enolate, so you're much
higher in energy.
So these things we talked about
before, about using
really strong bases to preform
the anion, those
are ways to do this.
But if you want to deal just
with hydroxide,
there's a way to do it.
Now, we already went through the
demonstration of showing
how you make tea by pouring hot
water through a
tea bag in a funnel.
But a much more efficient way is
to
use this Soxhlet extractor.
So the extractor looks like this
you boil liquid down
below, and you condense it up
above, and it drips down into
a paper cup that's holding the
tea or whatever it is.
And it begins to rise up, and
when it gets up to the top and
finally goes over the top, it
drains down, and then the
whole cycle starts over again.
So that's a much more efficient
way to do--
to extract to make tea.
But it's also a way to make
aldol because of what you put
in the cup.
So the liquid you're going to
use is acetone.
The liquid is acetone,
so it's distilling up, sitting
there for a while, and then
draining back, and distilling up
again.
Now, remember that it takes a
catalyst to make the aldol.
A base is what we've shown here.
So suppose you had a base that
was only in the cup.
Then the acetone will come and
sit in the cup and reach
equilibrium, if it's sitting
there for a while with the
base, which has just a little
bit of the aldol in it,
because the equilibrium lies to
the left.
But then it drains down into the
pot, where there's no
base, so it can't go back again.
But the dimer, of course, is
much heavier than
the starting material.
So it doesn't distill.
The acetone goes back up, drips
through again, makes a
little bit more, it drains in,
up a little more, a little
more, a little more.
So all you have to do is put in
that cup up above a base
which is not soluble in acetone.
Barium hydroxide is such a
thing.
So that's a really fancy way to
make an aldol when it was
unfavorable.
Using a Soxhlet extractor.
OK.
Now it's possible to do a
crossed aldol condensation
where the enolate comes from one
carbonyl compound, and the
carbonyl that gets attacked
comes from another one.
In particular, suppose you start
with what's called
acetophenone.
It's a methyl-phenyl ketone.
Make its anion.
And it attacks--
if it were to attack, itself,
with methyl and phenyl, the
equilibrium would be very
unfavorable.
It would be way too crowded,
right?
So this one won't work.
That's an unfavorable
equilibrium.
But suppose instead you use
benzaldehyde.
Now it's not hindered because
it's an aldehyde.
So you can make the product with
benzene here, benzene
here, and H here by this crossed
two different
reagents, this one and this one,
aldol condensation.
Now, it's clear that this one is
not going to react with
itself, with its own ketone,
because the product will be
too hindered.
But why won't the enolate of
that react with itself?
It would be much less hindered.
This is a trick question.
Why doesn't the enolate of this
carbonyl compound react
with the aldehyde? Ellen,
what would the enolate of this
be?
How do you make an enolate?
STUDENT: Take off the H.
PROFESSOR: Where do you take the
H from?
STUDENT: Umm.
PROFESSOR: From the carbon
that's adjacent to the carbonyl.
Right?
So that the pi star or the
carbonyl will
stabilize the anion.
So what's the story here?
STUDENT: Oh, there's
no H there.
PROFESSOR: There isn't any.
It's a benzene ring.
There's no hydrogen on that
carbon.
So this can't form an enolate,
and this
can't react with itself.
So they cross over without
complication.
So that one can't form an
enolate.
And you can then lose water to
make the alpha beta
unsaturated ketone.
Now I'll just go through this,
which I did on the board last
year and took a picture of.
This is the compound we just
made on the previous slide.
It's an alpha, beta-unsaturated
ketone.
And it undergoes what's called
conjugate addition.
That is, you expect a
nucleophile to react with the
carbonyl carbon, the pi star.
But if you have a situation like
this, cyanide could react
not only there, but also here.
And if it reacts here, and then
you put on a
proton on the O...
you'd have the enolate anion
once the cyanide is attacked
up at the top left here.
So there's the charge here,
charge here,
So you could put the proton
either place.
The more stable place to put the
proton is down here, so
you have a carbon oxygen double
bond, rather than to
put it on the oxygen, so you
have an enol.
We know that carbonyls are more
stable than enols.
So this is the product you get
from that.
And I think it's safest to call
it conjugate addition,
because you add to a double bond
that cyanide would not
normally add to.
Remember, alkenes are usually
attacked by electrophiles, not
nucleophiles.
But this one is special, because
adding here, you
generate a stable anion, the
enolate.
OK.
So that's called conjugate
addition.
Or sometimes it's called 1,
4-addition.
So here's the one, two, three,
four, position.
You add a hydrogen there and
cyanide here, that would be
1,4-addition to the thing.
The product, of course, would be
an enolate, but the enolate
will become a ketone.
So that's just the name that's
given this 1, 4-addition.
But conjugate, I think, is
better.
OK.
Now, if you react with the
Grignard reagent,
phenylmagnesium  bromide,
it does the same
thing cyanide does.
It undergoes conjugate addition,
and you get a 96%
yield of this.
And if you use copper, it turns
out that that sometimes
helps to get conjugate addition,
if you add it.
But if you use, instead of
phenylmagnesium bromide,
phenyllithium, then it doesn't
do the 1, 4-, or the
conjugate addition.
It adds, as you would naively
have expected, to
the carbonyl group.
So obviously, there's a lot of
subtlety involved here, and a
lot of lore.
I would certainly not have
expected you to know--
I would expect you to know that
you can add here, and
having thought about it a little
bit, I would expect you
to think that you can add here.
But as to which way it goes, and
why a Grignard reagent
goes here, and why copper helps
it, while phenyllithium
goes here--
that, I wouldn't expect you to
know.
That's the lore that comes from
being in
the business a while.
But when you've been around, you
know what to do.
You know to throw copper in, if
this is the kind
of product you want.
OK.
And the same kind of thing
happens with hydride addition.
So if you have this
cyclohexenone, and reduce it
with lithium aluminum hydride,
the hydride does what you
expect it to do.
It adds to the carbon of the
carbonyl, and you get this
unsaturated alcohol.
cyclohexenol, 97% yield.
But if you use a different
source of hydride, the BH4
minus instead of AlH4 minus,
then you get only a 59% yield
of this product, and you get
41%, the rest of it is the
material that's lost the double
bond.
So the double bond has been
reduced, too.
Now, BH3, remember, adds to
double bonds.
But BH4 minus doesn't.
And when BH3 three adds, it adds
an H, and also the boron,
and that's the way you get an
alcohol, remember, the
hydroboration/oxidation.
But BH4 minus is different.
It doesn't react with double
bonds.
And if you take this material
and react it with sodium
borohydride, it doesn't do that.
So that's not where this came
from.
Where it came from was having
the
first addition be conjugate.
So hydride added to this
position the end of the double
bond that's conjugated with the
carbonyl, as in the top
left there.
That made this enolate, which
then got protonated in this
position to give them the ketone
instead of the enol.
And now that carbonyl can be
reduced by borohydride, the
same way this one could at the
beginning,
and now you get the 41% of that.
So you must initially have
gotten almost equal amounts of
reduction of the carbonyl group
directly by 1, 2-addition
and conjugate addition, 41%
conjugate addition, which then
led to that.
So again, this is lore.
And if we drilled you on that,
you would know something.
You would be able to have quick
recall of it.
Having seen it, I expect you to
recognize things like that.
But I don't expect you to know
all the details.
In fact, I think no one knows
This is all sensitive to what
temperature, exactly what
salts you use, what solvent and
so on.
So it's a complicated thing.
Or adding the copper.
OK.
Now a very interesting reaction
is called the
Robinson annulation.
Annulation means making a ring.
And this was invented in 1935,
and here's the beginning of
the paper where it was invented
by Rapson, a graduate
student, and Sir Robert
Robinson, who got the Nobel
Prize for synthetic organic
chemistry.
So it's experiments on the
synthesis of substances
related to sterols.
So you remember steroids, these
hormones, are
six-membered ring, six-membered
ring,
six-membered ring, five-membered
ring, with
various lettuce hanging around
it.
So there are lots of these
different things.
And the 1930s through the 1950s
and '60s was the golden
age of steroid chemistry.
And remember, that was the basis
on which conformational
analysis was invented.
In 1958, Barton, who was working
in this field, started
looking at which side, axial,
equatorial and all that, that
was all done in the context of
steroids.
But what Robinson says here is,
"The methods for synthesis
of 1-5 diketones"--
So here's a ketone.
One, two, three, four, five.
So a 1-5 diketone.
"The methods for synthesis of 1
5-diketones have been
explored in this laboratory for
two reasons.
One, it was thought that
pinacols such as (I) might
furnish the characteristic
angle-methyl ketone group (II)
of estrone."
So estrone is a female hormone,
right?
And it has that five-membered
ring up in the top-right,
has a ketone there, and what's
called an angular methyl group
adjacent to it.
So how are you going to
synthesize that?
So he thought that that could
come from this via a pinacol
rearrangement.
We talked about the pinacol
Remember, what's going to happen
is you would protonate
here, lose water, cation,
methide shift.
So now you've got the methyl
there from this
five-membered ring.
So you need that compound if you
want to be able to
make it that way.
Where do you get a pinacol?
You get it from pinacol
reduction.
So you would get it from this
forming the bond across there.
And we talked about the pinacol
reduction, where you
put an electron on here, an
electron on here, the two free
radicals couple, and then you
have O minus, C-C bond, O minus.
And they get protonated and give
the pinacol.
OK.
So that would be the pinacol
reduction.
So that was what he was hoping
is a way to try to make this
five-membered ring with that
methyl group, which is hard to
put in there otherwise,
by intramolecular change," which
we would now call
rearrangement.
And a second reason was "the
diketones themselves, three,
might be dehydrated with the
formation of cyclcohexenones."
So you could make a six-membered
ring with a
double bond carbonyl.
Now, what do you notice about
that double bond?
He says you might be able to go
from here to here, so these
double shafted arrows are
thinking backwards.
It's called retrosynthesis.
What could something come from?
The ultimate arrow will be this
going to this.
But when you see this, you think
of this.
Why?
Why, when you see this
functional group, do you think
of this diketone?
You look at that functional
group, and what
would you call it?
Can you give a name to that?
Kate, can you think of any names
for functional groups there?
What's this functional group,
the C=O?
STUDENT: Ketone.
PROFESSOR: Ketone.
And this one?
STUDENT: An alkene.
PROFESSOR: An alkene.
So you could call it an eneone.
Right?
But then you wouldn't know where
the ene is.
So you have to say where the ene
is relative to the ketone
to get that functional group to
know that they're
conjugated.
So if you start with the ketone,
it's the alpha and
then the beta position.
So it's an alpha beta
unsaturated ketone.
And there's another name for
alpha,
beta-unsaturated ketones.
They're the dehydration product
of aldols.
So the aldol reaction, where you
make an anion here, it
attacks that carbonyl to make
OH, and then
you dehydrate it--
he says dehydrate it here--
lose the OH and an H here to
make the double bond.
So that's the reaction we just
talked about.
The aldol reaction.
So then you need this compound.
You need that diketone if you're
going to
make it that way.
And how will you make it?
You'll make it by forming the
red bond, attacking this
double bond here.
What kind of reaction is that?
Luke, you got an idea?
If you made an anion here, that
would
be an enolate anion.
Pulled an H off there.
OK?
So you can make the anion here.
And then you want to attack a
ketone, so you think of making
a bond from here to here.
But this is making a bond from
here to here.
Did you ever see anything like
that?
About eight minutes ago, we
talked
about conjugate addition.
Addition to the double bond
adjacent to the carbonyl.
Because if the anion attacks
here, then you have a minus
charge on this carbon adjacent
to the carbonyl.
It's an enolate anion.
So this is an example of
conjugate addition.
So what you would need, then,
this would be conjugate
addition to this ketone.
And that ketone, before you make
the red bond, is methyl
and a C=CH2,
vinyl.
So that's methyl vinyl ketone,
which is a very important
reagent for making these
six-membered ring compounds.
So the idea of making this ring
compound by way of methyl
vinyl ketone, attacking a
ketone, is called the Robinson
annulation procedure.
The way of forming a ring.
So a base to make the enolate,
and then methyl vinyl ketone.
So it takes this into two
six-membered rings adjacent to
one another with a carbonyl down
here, which is just like
what's in the bottom lefthand
corner of these steroids.
Six-membered ring with an oxygen
pointing down that way
and another six-membered ring.
So the Robinson annulation is
just the ticket for forming
this thing, and they often have
a methyl
group in that position.
So you see, these are the four
carbons that become these four
carbons in the product.
So to do that, you'd need an
enolate at this position doing
a conjugate addition to attack
here.
So this carbon becomes that
carbon.
Then you form an anion here at
that position,
an enolate, it is.
And beyond the carbonyl, there's
one more methyl group.
This one.
But once you've got that, then
once you've got the methyl
group here and still a ketone
here, then you can have the
anion of that methyl group, the
enolate, attack the
carbonyle, an aldol reaction,
dehydrate, and
you've got this thing.
So that all happens at once when
you use methyl vinyl
ketone as the ketone.
Except you have to be sure that
you've got the right
anion here, that the anion is,
at that position, the enolate
that you're starting with, and
not at that position.
And we'll address that on
Friday, how you make sure
you've got the right enolate.
And Woodward-- because on
Friday, we'll be talking about
Woodward's synthesis of the
steroid cortozone, where he
used Robinson's method.
We showed this picture before
last semester, and they're not
acknowledging one another's
presence here.
Both of them were quite...
Each of them, I'm sure, was
quite confident that he was
most important organic chemist
of the 20th century.
And what's especially
interesting is here You see
the double bond is not drawn,
but this is that
cyclohexenone, the product from
the Robinson annulation.
OK.
Then there's one called the
Claisen condensation, which is
now an ester.
But all these are the same.
You make an enolate, and you
react here with itself.
So in fact, when I made these
slides, I could use exactly
the same slide and just plug in
one group
different each time.
So as you look at these, you'll
be able to organize
them clearly in your mind.
So here now is an ester.
Why do we use RO minus rather
than hydroxide?
Because we don't want to make
the acid.
We want to keep the ester.
So we have RO minus, we talked
about that
before, make the enolate.
And now this one comes over and
gets attacked.
So it starts the same way an
aldol does, if the starting
material were an aldehyde or a
ketone.
But it's different because you
have a leaving group on here.
So when it comes back in, that
leaving group can leave. So
instead of getting an alcohol
from the group that gets
attacked, you get a carbonyl
group.
So it's a beta-ketoester.
Instead of beta-hydroxy ketone,
beta-hydroxy aldehyde--
that's the aldol reaction--
it's a beta-ketoester, because
you
had a leaving group.
So it's not an alcohol, right?
Now again, this equilibrium is
unfavorable, if you have more
complicated groups on here.
But at first, it looked like the
alkoxide was catalytic.
We used it here to make the
enolate, but then we got it
back again here, so it looks
like a catalyst that just
cycles around and around.
You don't need very much of it.
But this beta-ketoester is quite
acidic.
So it actually "eats up the
lye," as in saponification that
we talked about last time.
And that's good, because the
equilibrium here might have
been unfavorable.
But once you do this very
exothermic reaction, taking up
one of those hydrogens, then the
reaction
is favorable again.
Now here's nature's version of
the Claisen condensation.
They use the special ester.
Instead of oxygen, it's got
sulfur here.
But it does exactly the same
thing.
It makes the anion, it attacks,
you
get a beta-ketoester.
It's a thioester.
And coA is coenzyme A, so it's a
special R group that's
attached to make it an ester.
If you're interested, that's the
R group.
There's the SH that's going to
be that thing there.
But that will be for another
day.
So how does nature get around
the fact that this equilibrium
is unfavorable, that it would
come back?
It puts an extra CO2 in.
So instead of starting with this
being CH3, it starts with
an extra CO2 group on it here.
So it's a dicarbonyl compound.
Easier to form the anion.
Now, you might think, if that's
a negative charge, it's
going to be hard to form the
anion.
But in the enzyme where it's
held, this one is not ionized.
I'm not sure exactly how it's
tied up, but anyhow, it helps
make this one acidic, having the
carbonyl next door.
And then you get this product.
So it's malonyl, not acetyl.
And then the equilibrium is
driven by losing the CO2.
So that's how nature does
Claisen condensations.
Why?
Because it wants to store
energy, right?
So notice it's put this acetyl
group on the
original acid, or ester.
It's formed this new bond where
it attacked and had a
leaving group.
So then nature reduces it using
the reducing agent,
NADH, that we talked about.
So it becomes an alcohol.
And then it dehydrates.
It's a beta hydroxy carbonyl
compound.
Just like aldols, it dehydrates.
And then it gets reduced again
to put H2 in here.
So we have this product.
We started with having just one
methyl group with just two
carbons here, and now we have
one, two, three,
four carbons there.
And notice what you can do.
You can take this ester and plug
it in up above, and put
another two carbons on when you
come around to get this.
Then you can plug it in, put
another two carbons, another
two carbons.
So you can make a long chain of
reduced carbons ending in
an acid, or an ester, to start
with.
So these are fatty acids.
That's how you store the
energy of fuel to burn, as
these successive CH2 groups that
can be oxidized.
But the fatty acids that occur
in nature are all even numbers
of carbon, not odd numbers.
Because it makes them this way,
and always adds two
carbons at a time to the chain.
I'm going to say just two words
now--
more than two, but not many more
than two--
about carbohydrates.
So carbohydrate was named early
on.
I was going to look it up and
find out.
It must have been in the early
19th Century.
Once they could analyze them and
see they were
CH2O taken n times.
So carbohydrates.
A hydrate of carbon.
Right?
Now, Couper in 1858 had the idea
of tetravalence.
And once you had that, a number
of sugars had been
observed, but no one had any
idea what structure was, so it
was hard to talk about them.
You could talk about some of
their properties, but not,
obviously, about their
structure.
So if you have carbohydrate,
Couper would put two more
bonds on the carbon.
So you could make a chain of
these, say, six.
But this is unsatisfactory.
You've got to do something with
those two
bonds on the end.
You could make a carbon ring, a
six-membered ring,
cyclohexane with OHs all around.
But that's not what you do.
What Couper did in his very
first paper, you remember,
about structure, he gave a
structure for glucose.
and the structure he gave was
this.
What did he do with the extra
bonds?
How did he modify this chain in
order to get his structure?
Well, of course, remember there
are double oxygens where
in fact there should be a single
oxygen.
That's because of the--
But what else?
He took water and put H on one
end OH on the other.
And in fact, you can do that.
This is a gem-diol.
That's an aldehyde that's been
hydrated.
That's one way to do it.
Another way to do it is to
take--
this is what got lost when my
computer crashed.
So this one, notice, took the
HOH that was here, took the Hs
away, put one H up here, the
other H down there.
And this one took the two Hs
away from this one, put one H
up there, the other H down
there.
So these, then, are sugars, but
who knows
which one is which?
And this is a page from van 't
Hoff's--
that was 1858--
1874, stereochemistry.
What makes things optically
active?
Van 't Hoff, in his 1874 paper,
says these compounds
are optically active:
Glucose, levulose, lactose,
mannitol.
Because he's got four different
things on this
carbon, the four that are in the
middle
of the chain, right?
Or mannitol, the one where
you've added H to each end of
the aldehyde.
Then you still have these
things.
Or derivatives of mannitol, or
the diacid where you have an
acid at each end of the chain.
All these things were optically
active, right?
That's part of this.
So there were a number of sugars
known by that time.
But the really fine work began
to be done in the 1880s by
Heinrich Kiliani and Emil
Fischer.
And that will be a treat for
next time.